Tasha: 还有一个手套呢
Tasha: There's still a glove.
Tasha: 能拿给我一下吗
Tasha: Can you hand it to me?
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Lucia: 哎这好像不是手套
Lucia: Oh, this doesn't seem like a glove.
Jake:哎你小心点
Jake: Hey, be careful.
Lucia: sorry是那个厚的是吧
Lucia: Sorry, is it the thick one?
Jake:小心十分小心
Jake: Be very careful.
Jake:齐了是吧
Jake: Is it all here?
Tasha: 算了算了
Tasha: Forget it, forget it.
Lucia: 哦找到了
Lucia: Oh, found it.
Tasha: 端 过来了
Tasha: Bring it over.
Jake:然后我们这边还有多久大概
Jake: So how much time do we have left?
Jake:大概还有几分钟呀
Jake: About how many minutes?
Jake:五分钟好
Jake: Five minutes, okay.
Tasha: 5分钟
Tasha: 5 minutes.
Jake:呃5分钟之后把这个端上去
Jake: Uh, after 5 minutes, take this up.
Jake:然后稍微我直接开了就好
Jake: Then I'll just start it directly.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm.
Jake:对然后5分钟
Jake: Yes, then 5 minutes.
Jake:我我我就是基本上放视频了
Jake: I'll basically start the video.
Tasha: 能不能直接这种扣过来
Tasha: Can we flip this directly?
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What to do?
Lucia: 底下的那个盘子还是用这个抓吧
Lucia: Use the plate underneath or grab it with this.
Lucia: 这个嗯也给你带上
Lucia: This one, yeah, put it on.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What to do?
Lucia: 还是两个人一起还是怎么样
Lucia: Should we do it together or how?
Jake:耶
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:你扣上吧
Alice: You buckle it.
Tasha: 呃别太用力
Tasha: Uh, don't use too much force.
Lucia: 哎是4 盒是吧
Lucia: Hey, it's 4 boxes, right?
Lucia: 恩对
Lucia: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 有点歪反正小声
Lucia: It's a bit crooked, but quietly.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm.
其他人：还行哦
Others: It's okay.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
其他人：其实应该一个一个拿
Others: Actually, we should take them one by one.
Alice:变形
Alice: Transform
其他人：小心烫
其他人：其实这样也挺好的
Others: Actually, this is pretty good too.
Tasha: 没法关系 冷一冷
Tasha: No worries, let it cool down.
Tasha: 这个做的一点都不酥
Tasha: This is not crispy at all.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Shure: 选a
Shure: Choose A
其他人：选a
Others: Choose A
Shure: 选a是吗
Shure: Is it choosing A?
Shure: 还有不同答案吗
Shure: Any different answers?
其他人：好了OK了
Others: That's it, OK
其他人：来玩什么
Others: What are we playing?
Shure: 来C4D你
Shure: Let's do C4D
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: I don't know
Shure: 你们俩谁先他他他
Shure: Who's going first, you or you?
Shure: 他那他你确定
Shure: Are you sure about that?
Shure: 4D还是让给他
Shure: 4D, or let him do it?
其他人：那我2B好了
Others: Then I'll be 2B
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Shure: 好的BD
Shure: Alright, BD
Shure: CA然后你是c是吧好的
Shure: CA, and you're C, right? Okay
Shure: 公布正确答案
Shure: Announcing the correct answer
Shure: CC选项今年的主题叫做planet versus plastic
Shure: Option CC. This year's theme is called "Planet versus Plastic"
Jake:c
Jake: C
Shure: 就是星球对抗塑料
Shure: It's "Planet versus Plastic"
Shure: 是我们今年的世界进球日的主题
Shure: It's the theme for this year's World Goal Day
Shure: 然后恭喜
Shure: And congratulations
Shure: 像像相机同学
Shure: To the camera guy
其他人：对其他几个主题都
Others: Yes, all the other themes
其他人：产品是有过的还是没有的啊
Others: Are products that have been or haven't been, right?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Jake:好问题我们也不知道哈哈哈
Jake: Good question, we don't know either, haha
Alice:好问哈哈
Alice: Good question, haha
Shure: 不不
Shure: No, no
其他人：这个选项是生造出来的
Others: This option was made up
Tasha: 还是从音节里面选
Tasha: Or chosen from the syllables
Shure: 不这个
Shure: No, this
Jake:这所有的题目都是哈哈
Jake: All the questions are, haha
Tasha: 这也告诉别人
Tasha: This also tells others
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 但是答案保真的这个是
Shure: But the answers are genuine, this is
其他人：哈这是可以说的吗
Others: Haha, can we say this?
Shure: 啊没有没有这个
Shure: Ah, no, no, this
Shure: 其他确实是都没有
Shure: The rest indeed haven't
Shure: 没有出现过的都是胡搜出来的
Shure: Never appeared before, they were all made up
Shure: 然后这题三个彼此
Shure: Then this question has three parts.
Shure: 这怎么还有氛围组呢
Shure: Why is there a vibe group?
Tasha: 这12块钱就到手了
Tasha: This 12 bucks are in the bag.
Shure: 下
Shure: Next.
其他人：我受不了了
Others: I can't take it anymore.
Shure: 下一题第7题
Shure: Next question, question 7.
Shure: 地球的南极冰啊
Shure: The Antarctic ice of the Earth.
Shure: 地球的南极冰盖
Shure: The Antarctic ice cap of the Earth.
Shure: 锁定了多少比百分比的淡水
Shure: How much percentage of fresh water is locked in it?
Shure: a大约50%
Shure: a. About 50%
Shure: b大约70% c大约90% d大约30%
Shure: b. About 70% c. About 90% d. About 30%
Shure: C2B
Shure: C to B.
Jake:牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Jake:哦欢迎你
Jake: Oh, welcome.
Jake:好啊早上好
Jake: Alright, good morning.
Jake:早上好
Jake: Good morning.
Tasha: 这是她男朋友吗
Tasha: Is that her boyfriend?
其他人：不是
Others: No.
Shure: 好那没有其他的选项了
Shure: Okay, no other options.
Tasha: 啊没事
Tasha: Ah, it's fine.
Tasha: 哎你带美瞳了吗
Tasha: Hey, are you wearing colored contacts?
Shure: 公布答案杨老板 90%
Shure: Announce the answer, Jake. 90%.
其他人：没有
Others: No.
Jake:90
Jake: 90.
Tasha: 哇你的眼睛好好好棕啊
Tasha: Wow, your eyes are really brown.
Shure: 我们其实世界呃
Shure: Actually, our world, uh...
Shure: 就是地球上最大的淡水资源
Shure: The Earth's largest fresh water resource...
Tasha: 你看我带了吗
Tasha: Do you see me wearing them?
Shure: 都是南极冰盖锁定的
Shure: ...is all locked in the Antarctic ice cap.
其他人：啊
Others: Ah.
Tasha: 我带了棕色美瞳跟你没带是一个色
Tasha: I'm wearing brown contacts, and they look the same as your natural color.
其他人：这有预订 吗
Others: Is this booked?
Shure: 对所以是90%
Shure: Yes, so it's 90%.
Tasha: 感觉
Tasha: Feels...
其他人：新的
Others: New.
其他人：是吗
Others: Really?
Shure: 然后这题也三个例子吧
Shure: Then this question also has three examples.
Tasha: 嗯是吧嗯
Tasha: Yeah, right?
Shure: 提问冰盖跟奶盖什么关系
Shure: Question, what's the connection between an ice cap and a milk cap?
Alice:提问冰盖跟奶盖什么关系
Alice: Question, what's the connection between an ice cap and a milk cap?
Jake:问
Jake: Ask
Shure: 呃好问题
Shure: Uh, good question
Katrina: 好关系哈哈哈
Katrina: Good relationship, hahaha
Jake:题好问题
Jake: Good question, good question
Tasha: 那是刘宇轩男朋友吗
Tasha: Is that Liu Yuxuan's boyfriend?
Shure: 就是在我说说你听听
Shure: Just let me explain, you listen
其他人：不是
Others: No
Tasha: 不是啊哦
Tasha: No? Oh
Shure: 在想当初大约3,500万年前
Shure: Thinking back to about 35 million years ago
Tasha: 我没有
Tasha: I didn't
其他人：你去问你去问问去
Others: You go ask, go ask
Tasha: 我不问啊
Tasha: I'm not asking
Shure: 继女娲补天的时候
Shure: During the time when Nuwa mended the sky
Tasha: 你去问问吧
Tasha: You go ask
Shure: 创造了一个双胞胎
Shure: Created a pair of twins
Tasha: 嘿菠萝
Tasha: Hey, Pineapple
Shure: 一个叫冰盖
Shure: One was called Ice Cap
Shure: 一个叫奶盖
Shure: The other was called Milk Cap
Shure: 对大概就是这么回事您说
Shure: Yeah, that's basically it. You say
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Tasha: 你们团队中有哪些人是单身呀
Tasha: Who in your team is single?
Tasha: 我感觉没有几个单身
Tasha: I feel like there aren't many singles
Tasha: 你是单身
Tasha: Are you single?
Tasha: 你也不是
Tasha: You're not either
Tasha: 那有谁是单身
Tasha: So who is single?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No
Shure: 他是就是占占了全球淡水的多少
Shure: He just occupies how much of the global fresh water
其他人：我们四个都不是
Others: None of us four are single
其他人：你们四个跟刘帅跟葛娃查跟我都不是
Others: The four of you, Liu Shuai, Ge Wacha, and I are not single
Katrina: 但是你得说是淡水
Katrina: But you should say it's fresh water
Katrina: 90%应该只是水就不是淡水
Katrina: 90% is just water, not fresh water
Tasha: 你们四个不是单身
Tasha: You four are not single
Katrina: 你可以看看有没有
Katrina: You can check if there are any
其他人：都是单身
Others: All are single
Jake:没有人在搜一下
Jake: No one is searching
Katrina: 在搜一下那个
Katrina: Searching that
Tasha: 他不是也有吗
Tasha: Doesn't he also have one?
其他人：对啊
Others: Yeah
Tasha: 你们你们你们一共多少个人的团队
Tasha: How many people are in your team altogether?
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh my
Shure: 有人提出了challenge
Shure: Someone has proposed a challenge.
其他人：团队吗
Others: As a team?
其他人：嗯在场上至少四个
Others: Yeah, at least four people on the field.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake:直播直播搜索
Jake: Live streaming search.
Shure: 冰盖的面积超过这个14其他人：
Shure: The ice cap area exceeds this 14...
其他人：这样一场超过这个十那就
Others: ...if it exceeds this 10, then...
其他人：后面6个0平方公里
Others: ...another 6 zeros square kilometers.
Tasha: 他就杨景航
Tasha: He's just Yang Jinghang.
其他人：厚度达到4公里以上
Others: The thickness reaches over 4 kilometers.
Tasha: 是单身
Tasha: He's single.
其他人：所含的冰量
Others: The volume of ice...
Jake:我我都不知道他是不是啊
Jake: I don't even know if he is.
其他人：相当于地球上所吸干水质量的约70%
Others: ...is about 70% of Earth's fresh water mass.
Tasha: 他这么单
Tasha: He's so single.
Tasha: 他这么神秘
Tasha: He's so mysterious.
其他人：我又不跟他聊
Others: I don't even talk to him.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Tasha: 对那应该是
Tasha: Yeah, that must be it.
Tasha: 哇大家都好都好忙碌只有他
Tasha: Wow, everyone is so busy, only him...
Alice:是水有70%
Alice: Yes, water makes up 70%.
其他人：老板是这样
Others: That's the boss.
Alice:陆地有30%
Alice: Land makes up 30%.
Alice:然后这个水的70%的水里面有90%的水
Alice: And 70% of that water, 90% is fresh water.
其他人：我老板好孤单
Others: My boss is so lonely.
Tasha: 你老板对他好像是男神啊
Tasha: Your boss seems like a heartthrob.
其他人：他好像是单身
Alice:是才是啊对
Alice: Yes, he is, right.
Tasha: 这这没关系
Tasha: That doesn't matter.
Tasha: 嗯没关系
Tasha: Yeah, it doesn't matter.
Tasha: 好酷啊
Tasha: So cool.
Lucia: 大家好认真
Lucia: Everyone is so serious.
Lucia: 哈哈哈没想到哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, didn't expect that, haha.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Tasha: 是吧但是长了痘有点多
Tasha: Right, but he's got a lot of acne.
Shure: 是的那
Shure: Yes, so...
Tasha: 为啥呀嗯
Tasha: Why though, hmm?
Alice:对因为有的水不是淡水
Alice: Yeah, because some water isn't fresh water.
其他人：嗯不知道就是脸皮肤粗
Others: Hmm, no idea, just rough skin.
Lucia: 原来只有我们在弱智旁
Lucia: So, we're the only ones next to the fool.
Shure: 转移一下资产
Shure: Transfer some assets.
Katrina: 但我不确定哪3个是原来的
Katrina: But I'm not sure which three were the original ones.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
其他人：远远的看还行
Others: It looks fine from a distance.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 然后那我们再奖励一枚币子给
Shure: Alright, then we'll reward a coin to...
Shure: 查出正确答案的同学
Shure: The student who finds the correct answer.
Tasha: 我不是
Tasha: It's not me.
Shure: 非常好
Shure: Very good.
Shure: 那么下一题
Shure: Now, next question.
Shure: 地球的南极
Shure: The South Pole of Earth.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 他让我梅开二度的难堪
Shure: He's making me embarrassed for the second time.
Shure: 从太阳到地球
Shure: From the Sun to the Earth.
Shure: 阳光需要多长时间到达
Shure: How long does it take for sunlight to reach?
Shure: 这个
Shure: This...
Shure: 其实是我们好像高中那种经常算的
Shure: We used to calculate this a lot in high school.
Shure: 哎呦已经有两位同学举手了
Shure: Oh, two students have already raised their hands.
Shure: 8分19秒
Shure: 8 minutes 19 seconds.
Shure: 哎我其实你们两个同时举手
Shure: Oh, actually, you both raised your hands at the same time.
Shure: 那你们还有其他答案吗
Shure: Do you have any other answers?
Shure: 你选D20前
Shure: You chose D20 before.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: Q a结束之后
Tasha: After the Q&A ends.
Tasha: 然后就开始分享故事是吗
Tasha: Then we'll start sharing stories, right?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Tasha: Q a结束之后好呀
Tasha: After the Q&A ends, alright.
Shure: 你知道这个地意味着什么意思吗
Shure: Do you know what this "D" means?
其他人：好像是吧 好像还有参观 一下房间
Others: Seems like it, and there's also a room tour.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 就是我们的表转了20圈
Shure: It means our watch has spun 20 times.
Tasha: 还有互相参观房间的项目
Tasha: There's also a room tour activity.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 才有一天会看到太阳
Shure: Only then will you see the sun in a day.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Alice:确保一定有一个正确答案
Alice: Make sure there's at least one correct answer.
Alice:为我们的顺利进行
Alice: For the sake of smooth progress.
Shure: 这这位同学纠正了我的
Shure: This student corrected my...
Shure: 我的错误
Shure: My mistake.
Shure: 是表转了40圈
Shure: The clock turned 40 times.
Shure: 是20圈啊
Shure: It's 20 times.
Shure: 对对对我舒服了
Shure: Yes, yes, yes, I feel better now.
Shure: 哎正确答案就谁
Shure: Hey, who got the correct answer?
Shure: 是吧对
Shure: Right, right?
Shure: 是8分19秒
Shure: It's 8 minutes 19 seconds.
Shure: 大家还记得那个怎么算的吗
Shure: Does everyone still remember how to calculate that?
其他人：谁问你了
Others: Who asked you?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Shure: 是是就其实就是这么简单对
Shure: Yeah, it's actually that simple.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina: 是
Katrina: Yes.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
其他人：谁谁距离多少
Others: Who, who is at what distance?
其他人：谁谁喂你了
Others: Who, who fed you?
其他人：这样的所以如果真的是20天的话
Others: So if it really is 20 days...
其他人：我只记得光伏
Others: I only remember photovoltaic.
其他人：那那南京应该肯定不会占地球了
Others: Then Nanjing definitely wouldn't occupy the earth.
Tasha: 二九九七九二四五八
Tasha: 29972458.
其他人：但是45%最起码
Others: But at least 45%.
其他人：太阳没了地球还能二然太阳
Others: The sun is gone, but the earth can still have the sun.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
其他人：那么问题太阳是持续发光
Others: The question is, the sun keeps shining.
其他人：它又不是歘一下然后又熄灭
Others: It's not like it shines and then goes out.
Shure: 你们你们2位
Shure: You two.
Shure: 每人两个
Shure: Each of you, two.
其他人：所以会另一方面
Others: So on the other hand...
其他人：感谢是如果这个样子的话
Others: Thanks, if it's like this...
其他人：也没什么事儿
Others: It's no big deal.
其他人：太要坏掉了的话再活20天哈
Others: If the sun is broken, then live for another 20 days, huh?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
其他人： 咱们现在看到是8分钟之前的阳光
Shure: 很乐观
Shure: Very optimistic.
其他人：也就是说我先看了8分钟之前的你
Others: So I'm looking at you from 8 minutes ago.
Tasha: 哇好有道理啊
Tasha: Wow, makes so much sense.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Shure: 下一个问题
Shure: Next question
Lucia: 哈哈哈神经病
Lucia: Hahaha, you're crazy
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
其他人：谁谁谁问你了哈哈哈
Others: Who asked you? Hahaha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahahaha
Shure: 陨石
Shure: Meteorite
Shure: 为什么每次都能精准的砸到陨石坑
Shure: Why does it always hit the meteor crater accurately?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 谁把这个问题加进去了
Lucia: Who added this question?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 这是一个开放性问题
Shure: This is an open-ended question
Shure: 根据你们的回答
Shure: Based on your answers
Shure: 我进行判断
Shure: I'll make a judgment
Shure: 给你们发币
Shure: And give you points
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 好好好
Lucia: Alright, alright
Shure: 这个每人都来回答一下来
Shure: Everyone should answer this one
其他人：这可以转化成一个前述范式的问题
Others: This can be turned into a previous question pattern
Jake:其他人：
Jake: Others:
其他人：：就是有陨石之坑
Others: It's just a meteor crater
其他人：这是一个潜潜制兵器
Others: This is a hidden weapon
其他人：然后它可以导致后面的问题
Others: And it can lead to the next question
其他人：那么如果前面问题是t的话
Others: So if the previous question is t
其他人：后面的问题肯定是一个陨石之坑
Others: The next question is definitely a meteor crater
其他人：所以说肯定有隐士
Others: So there must be a hermit
其他人：但如果前面那陨石坑的话
Others: But if the previous is a meteor crater
其他人：它这个这个
Others: Then this, this
其他人：这个病题始终是真的
Others: This question is always true
Tasha: 他已经得满分了
Tasha: He already got full marks
其他人：呵呵这这是奖励他
Others: Hehe, this is his reward
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 虽然很想同意这个话
Shure: Although I really want to agree with this
其他人：只能说谈不了异地恋
Others: Just can't do long-distance relationships
Shure: 但是呢还
Shure: But still
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Tasha: 你刚刚是不是还想说嘿
Tasha: Were you just about to say "hey"?
Tasha: 普罗
Tasha: Pro...
Tasha: 刘宇轩是你女朋友吗
Tasha: Is Liu Yuxuan your girlfriend?
Tasha: 现在你发现跟他无法交谈
Tasha: Now you find that you can't talk to him.
Tasha: 认可吧认可认可认可认可认可
Tasha: Acknowledge it, acknowledge it, acknowledge, acknowledge, acknowledge.
Tasha: 我们俩至少跟他不在一条线上
Tasha: At least the two of us are not on the same page as him.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 那我们宣判反方一
Shure: Then let's announce the verdict for the opposition.
其他人：我我跟金康是一种
Others: I, I have the same view as Jin Kang.
Shure: 正方一变赢了
Shure: The first proposition won.
Tasha: 你跟金康是一种
Tasha: You have the same view as Jin Kang?
其他人：不是我们跟金康是一种
Others: No, we have the same view as Jin Kang.
Shure: 好你先思考然后
Shure: Okay, you think about it first, then...
Katrina: 我觉得是因为陨石自带GPS系统
Katrina: I think it's because the meteorite has its own GPS system.
其他人：他回答这个问题太专业了
Others: He answered that question too professionally.
Katrina: 他肯定能精确定位到陨石
Katrina: He can definitely pinpoint the meteorite's location.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina: 对不对有没有道理
Katrina: Right? Does it make sense?
Tasha: 也不知道他是湖州的还是真的
Tasha: I don't know if he's from Huzhou or if he's serious.
Tasha: 然后就开始太正经了
Tasha: Then he starts getting too serious.
其他人：有一点超出我的level了
Others: It's a bit beyond my level.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 你好害羞啊哈哈
Shure: You're so shy, haha.
Tasha: 拿个饮料喝
Tasha: Grab a drink.
Shure: 你有你有想到什么反例来反驳他吗
Shure: Do you have any counterexamples to refute him?
Lucia: 没有选项
Lucia: No options.
Tasha: 噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun.
Shure: 下一个问题
Shure: Next question.
Shure: 吃止痛药打架算开挂吗
Shure: Does taking painkillers before a fight count as cheating?
Lucia: 这跟地球人都没关系了
Lucia: This has nothing to do with Earthlings.
Shure: 这跟地球人没关系吗
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈已经有同学发现了盲点哈
Lucia: Hahaha, some students have already discovered the blind spot, ha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:是我们从弱智吧找的问题
Alice: This is a problem we found on that dumb site.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Oh
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 好炸呀杨老师在
Tasha: It's so explosive with Mr. Yang here.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 你看二位二位学者
Shure: Look at these two scholars.
Lucia: 啊植物的三倍体是吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Ah, triploids in plants, right? Hahaha
Katrina: 3 媒体
Katrina: Three media
Shure: 来来来这个是
Shure: Come on, come on, this is...
Jake:还有一个问题
Jake: There's another question.
Jake:之前从0到第14题中间有一个
Jake: Before, from question 0 to 14, there was one in the middle...
Jake:其实只有13题
Jake: Actually, there were only 13 questions.
Shure: 对刚刚有一个旗号
Shure: Yeah, there was a flag just now.
Shure: 没有大家有发现吗
Shure: Did anyone notice that?
Shure: 这是一个彩蛋问题
Shure: It's an Easter egg question.
Shure: 这个是一个5分的问题
Shure: It's worth 5 points.
Shure: C这是一个竖
Shure: C, this is a vertical...
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 重复的就是为了迷惑你
Shure: The repetition is meant to confuse you.
Shure: 所以他遗漏了啊
Shure: So it was skipped, huh?
Shure: 那重复的不算
Shure: The repeated one doesn't count.
Shure: 那个遗漏了哪
Shure: Where did it skip?
Shure: 哪个题号
Shure: Which question number?
Shure: 大家有注意到吗
Shure: Did anyone notice?
其他人：0-13
Others: 0-13
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Tasha: 好吗
Tasha: Okay?
Shure: 啊 0-13对
Shure: Ah, 0-13, right.
Shure: 0-13他他说7
Shure: 0-13, he said 7.
Tasha: 这是什么说出来
Tasha: What's this? Say it out loud.
Shure: 9
Shure: 9.
其他人：1212
Others: 12, 12.
Tasha: 这什么东西
Tasha: What's this thing?
其他人：报数
Others: Count off
Shure: 这这这位同学呢
Shure: This, this, what about this student?
Tasha: 不是90吗
Tasha: Isn't it 90?
其他人：要猜一个没有的数字啊
Others: You have to guess a number that's not picked yet.
其他人： 99
Others: 99
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 哎哥喝醉了
Katrina: Hey, he's drunk.
Shure: 他猜过了7
Shure: He already guessed 7.
Shure: 他猜过了9
Shure: He already guessed 9.
Shure: 他猜过了12
Shure: He already guessed 12.
Shure: 对 0-13里面
Shure: Yeah, within 0-13.
其他人：哦0-13里面
Others: Oh, within 0-13.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 13就是上一集哈哈
Shure: 13 was in the previous round, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈看来会议
Jake: Hahaha looks like the meeting...
Alice:老是这种难题
Alice: Always such tough questions.
Alice:我们家刘婷就不参加了
Alice: Liu Ting in our family won't participate.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Shure: 猜一个吧
Shure: Just guess one.
Shure: 十难难道要要遗落了吗
Shure: Is 10 going to be left out?
其他人：10
Others: 10
Shure: 这个给大家缩小一下范围
Shure: Let me narrow it down for everyone.
其他人：5
Others: 5
Shure: 在啊这个数它不是一个质数
Shure: Well, this number is not a prime number.
Alice:4
Alice: 4
Tasha: 帮我说个3
Tasha: Say 3 for me.
其他人：三是质数
Others: Three is a prime number.
Lucia: 3
Tasha: 算什么
Tasha: What is it?
其他人：四四四
Others: Four, four, four
Shure: 8你
Shure: 8 you
Shure: 继续 12
Shure: Continue, 12
其他人：四四四四
Others: Four, four, four, four
Tasha: 11
其他人：6
Others: 6
其他人：11是质数 吗
Others: Is 11 a prime number?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Tasha: 到底在说什么东西
Tasha: What are you guys talking about?
Alice:不是质数
Alice: It's not a prime number.
Shure: 5也是质数
Shure: 5 is a prime number too.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Tasha: 为什么我能精准的命中这些东西
Tasha: Why can I hit these things so accurately?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 你们在说什么
Tasha: What are you all talking about?
其他人：二三五七十一
Others: 2, 3, 5, 7, 11
Tasha: 1
Alice:一人猜一个
Alice: Everyone guess one.
Alice:5质数哈哈
Alice: 5 is a prime number, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Lucia: 7年没写过数学了哈
Lucia: Haven't done math in 7 years, ha.
Shure: 哈行
Shure: Haha, alright.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 他坚持是5
Shure: He insists it's 5.
Shure: 那我们也没有办法
Shure: Well, we can't do anything about that.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 您您8
Shure: You, you, 8
Jake:不
Jake: No
其他人：哈哈哈不仅不听问题而且还一直问
Others: Hahaha, not only does he not listen to the question, he keeps asking.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 不是指数
Shure: Not an exponent.
Shure: 猜一个猜一个猜一个猜一个
Shure: Guess one, guess one, guess one, guess one.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 给面给面给面
Shure: Be nice, be nice, be nice.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha: 合理啊
Tasha: Makes sense.
Shure: 他给我面子
Shure: He's giving me face.
Shure: 我的室友们他给我面子
Shure: My roommates respect me.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
其他人：别的别掉在衣上吗
Others: Don't drop it on your clothes.
Shure: 好吧好吧那
Shure: Alright, alright then.
Jake:翻翻呗
Jake: Flip it over.
Shure: 我我记住了是6
Shure: I remember, it's 6.
Tasha: 是的真真的
Tasha: Yes, really.
其他人：真的
Others: Really.
其他人：脚在挨上吧
Others: Feet are on the line.
Alice:没人猜啊
Alice: No one guessed?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Shure: 所以没人猜
Shure: So no one guessed.
Alice:6啊
Alice: It's 6.
Tasha: 是的啊到底是哪挨
Tasha: Yes, which one is it?
Jake:确实没人才
Jake: Indeed, no one guessed.
其他人：是的啊到底是哪挨
Others: Yes, which one is it?
Shure: 所以所以我们这个大奖只能留掉
Shure: So, so we can only keep the grand prize.
Tasha: 学的很好
Tasha: Learned well.
Tasha: 到底是几啊
Tasha: What number is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈是几啊是几啊
Tasha: Haha, what number is it?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
其他人： 你猜对了
Others: You guessed it right.
Alice:6
Alice: 6.
Shure: 6
Shure: 6.
Tasha: 不是有人猜了
Tasha: Someone did guess it.
Jake:确实一个人都没猜到
Jake: Indeed, no one guessed it.
Jake:99倒是有人猜
Jake: Someone guessed 99.
其他人：给我5个吧
Others: Give me 5.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure: 那
Shure: Then.
Shure: 我们其实就应该到我们的action time了
Shure: We should actually move to our action time.
Shure: 就我们的拍卖时间
Shure: Our auction time.
Shure: 那我们先有请我们的host
Shure: Let's invite our host.
Shure: 我们的这房间的主人们
Shure: The owners of this room.
Shure: 先来拍一拍东西
Shure: Let's start auctioning things.
Tasha: 哦小锤子
Tasha: Oh, a little hammer.
Shure: 来掌声有请第一位
Shure: Let's give a warm welcome to our first guest
Alice:不是我还没拿
Alice: Wait, I haven't grabbed it yet
Jake:我们先统计一下
Jake: Let's count up first
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Shure: 大家手上都有多少币
Shure: How many coins does everyone have?
Tasha: 我身上有币吗
Tasha: Do I have any coins?
Katrina: 有几个了
Katrina: How many do we have?
其他人：没有啊
Others: None
Tasha: 工作人员为什么没有币
Tasha: Why don't the staff have any coins?
Tasha: 我拍什么东西
Tasha: What am I supposed to shoot?
其他人：回答问题
Others: Answer questions
Tasha: 不是
Tasha: No
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Tasha: 问一下吧
Tasha: Let's ask
其他人：有没有可能是
Others: Is it possible that...
其他人：有没有可能是雨轩
Others: Is it possible that it's Yuxuan?
其他人：不晓得哦
Others: I don't know
Katrina: 哈哈哈被劈一下
Katrina: Hahaha, got struck
Tasha: 那还邀请
Tasha: Then why invite
Lucia: 我是不是也得把我的小狗接上来
Lucia: Should I bring my puppy up too?
其他人：有没有可能是
Others: Is it possible that...
Katrina: 你们俩一人一只小狗吗
Katrina: Do you both have a puppy each?
Tasha: 就是朋友都行
Tasha: Friends are fine too
Lucia: 水母没有灯珠
Lucia: The jellyfish has no light
其他人：静候佳音好吗
Others: Awaiting good news, okay?
Lucia: 它现在不是灯
Lucia: It's not a light now
Lucia: 它只是水母
Lucia: It's just a jellyfish
Lucia: 哈哈哈行
Lucia: Hahaha okay
其他人：我嗑不了一点
Others: I can't even snack a bit
Lucia: 我去请狗了
Lucia: I'm going to get the dog
Tasha: 为什么你嗑的了
Tasha: Why can you snack?
Tasha: 我不嗑我也不嗑
Tasha: I can't snack, I don't snack
Tasha: 对啊没有没有没有
Tasha: Yeah, no, no, no
Tasha: 娇气与啊不
Tasha: Spoiled, uh, no
Tasha: 不管是哪一款吧
Tasha: No matter which one it is
Tasha: 反正就没有那个感觉
Tasha: I just don't feel it
Tasha: 不是人家关你屁事
Tasha: It's none of your business
其他人：我不能嗑了
Others: I can't snack anymore
Tasha: 有帅哥给我介绍一个
Tasha: If there's a handsome guy, introduce me one
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hey
其他人：这些鞋都能录到特别清楚
Others: All these shoes are recorded so clearly.
Tasha: 谢哥有帅哥给我介绍一个
Tasha: Hey Shure, introduce me to a handsome guy.
Tasha: 刘帅帅吧
Tasha: Choiszt is handsome, right?
其他人：够帅吧人家
Others: Yeah, he's pretty handsome.
其他人：人家人家刘帅了
Others: He's totally Choiszt.
Tasha: 哎介绍一个靠谱点的
Tasha: Hey, introduce someone reliable.
其他人：有什么要求
Others: What are your requirements?
其他人：我给你介绍你说
Others: I'll introduce someone, just tell me.
Tasha: 你说
Tasha: You tell me.
Tasha: 我同学
Tasha: My classmate.
Tasha: 长什么样子
Tasha: What does he look like?
其他人：你看我所有人挑到哪个
Others: Look, out of all the people I picked, which one?
其他人： 这个
Others: This one.
Shure: 我们
Shure: We...
Shure: 我们统计完自己手上都有多少币了吗
Shure: Have we counted how many coins each of us has?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Huh?
Shure: 来来报个数
Shure: Come on, report your numbers.
其他人：哈对不起我不是故意
Others: Haha, sorry, I didn't mean it.
Katrina: 啥呀
Katrina: What?
Shure: 自己手上有多少币
Shure: How many coins do you have?
Alice:20
Alice: 20.
Shure: 那个谢外
Shure: Except for Shye.
其他人：现在有人找我要他让我帮他拿
Others: Someone is asking me to help them hold.
Shure: 外面的场记
Shure: The stage manager outside.
Shure: 谢宾主来新民主
Shure: Shye is welcoming new democracy.
其他人：哎
Others: Hey.
Shure: 哎记一下账本
Shure: Hey, record it in the ledger.
Shure: 现在大家手里的币子
Shure: Now, the coins everyone has.
其他人：长得跟刘帅很像
Others: Looks a lot like Choiszt.
其他人：不要
Others: No, don't.
Shure: 对你记
Shure: Yeah, write it down.
Shure: 因为你到
Shure: Because you'll...
Tasha: 姐评价一下
Tasha: Sis, give an evaluation.
Shure: 到时候发钱包嘛
Shure: Hand out wallets later.
Katrina: 1515
Katrina: 1515.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Shure: 呃报一个姓名或者代号
Shure: Uh, report a name or a code name.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
其他人： 突然
Others: Suddenly.
Katrina: 小杜呗
Katrina: Xiao Du
Shure: 小杜小杜有15个币子
Shure: Xiao Du, Xiao Du has 15 coins
Katrina: 小杜哈哈哈
Katrina: Xiao Du, hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
其他人：哪个杜儿
Others: Which Du?
Katrina: 小杜
Katrina: Xiao Du
Shure: 杜安迪的杜哈哈哈
Shure: Du Andy's Du, hahaha
其他人：15
Others: 15
Tasha: 他有15个币
Tasha: He has 15 coins
Shure: 这位这位同学
Shure: This, this student
其他人：你是你是谁啊
Others: Who are you?
Shure: 11
Tasha: 小毕哈哈哈
Tasha: Xiao Bi, hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
其他人：小h
Others: Xiao H
其他人：多少个 12个
Others: How many? 12
Tasha: 那是谁邀请来的
Tasha: Who invited him?
Shure: 11
其他人：饺子啊还有谁啊
Others: Dumplings, who else?
其他人：我们俩都是8个
Others: We both have 8 each
其他人：分别你是谁
Others: Who are you?
其他人：小l你也是小l
Others: Xiao L, you too, Xiao L
Alice:你就大l吧哈哈哈
Alice: Then you can be Big L, hahaha
其他人：XL
Others: XL
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Tasha: 呃呃
Tasha: Uh uh
其他人：行不了一点
Others: Not possible at all
Tasha: 哈哈你自己先
Tasha: Haha, you go first
其他人：这个不行是吧
Others: This one won't work, right?
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one
其他人：这个不行
Others: This one won't work
Tasha: 我是智性恋你懂吗
Tasha: I'm sapiosexual, you know?
其他人：智性恋多丑都行
Others: Sapiosexual, no matter how ugly
Tasha: 哈哈哈是这样子的
Tasha: Hahaha, that's right
其他人：是这样子
Others: That's right
Lucia: 那你倒着哈哈
Lucia: Then you tell us, haha
Tasha: 嗯我是智性恋
Tasha: Yes, I'm sapiosexual
Tasha: 知道什么叫智性恋吗
其他人：JK
Others: JK
Tasha:  JK JK是什么啊
Tasha: JK? What's JK?
Tasha: 啊JK智性恋
Tasha: Oh, JK means sapiosexual.
Tasha: 智性恋
Tasha: Sapiosexual.
Shure: 唱吧唱吧
Shure: Sing, sing.
其他人：就是在一年学历的时候
Others: It's during the first year of education.
Shure: 新民主新民主记完了吗
Shure: New democracy, have you finished it?
其他人：记好了记好4个人是吧
Others: Yes, we finished it. Four people, right?
Shure: 还有一个
Shure: There's one more.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Shure: 那个楠楠有两个
Shure: Nan Nan has two.
其他人：多少个
Others: How many?
其他人：就两个
Others: Just two.
其他人：：我刚贿赂他他没给我哈哈
Others: I just bribed him, but he didn't give me anything. Haha.
Shure: 主要老板
Shure: Mainly the boss.
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 老板一直盯着我
Shure: The boss keeps watching me.
Shure: 我这不好不好做事
Shure: It's hard to get things done this way.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:哈暗箱操作
Alice: Haha, underhanded operations.
Lucia: 走了
Lucia: I'm leaving.
Shure: 来来来你要怎么贿赂我
Shure: Come on, how are you going to bribe me?
Shure: 给给给给你3个吧
Shure: Here, here, I'll give you three.
Tasha: 这我被笨蛋美女包围了都哈哈
Tasha: I'm surrounded by dumb beauties. Haha.
Shure: 给你凑一下5个吧好吧
Shure: I'll round it up to five for you, okay?
Jake:好那我们就开始
Jake: Alright, let's get started.
Tasha: 他都已经被笨蛋美女包围了
Tasha: He's already surrounded by dumb beauties.
Shure: 好开始先
Shure: Okay, let's start first.
Jake:先
Jake: First.
Tasha: 没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Shure: 是不是房间参观
Shure: Are we touring the room?
Tasha: 对真的身边女生不能多
Tasha: Yes, really, there shouldn't be too many girls around.
Jake:先拍吧
Jake: Let's shoot first.
Shure: 好那就先拍吧
Shure: Okay, let's shoot first then.
Shure: 把
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 这把这一层的任务咱们大家都做完先
Shure: Let's finish the tasks on this floor first.
Tasha: 越少越好
Tasha: The fewer, the better.
Tasha: 有助于培养感情
Tasha: It helps build relationships.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 那我们进入到了激动人心的auction time
Shure: Now we enter the exciting auction time
Tasha: 到了激动人心的ocean time
Tasha: The exciting ocean time
Shure: 拍卖时间
Shure: Auction time
Tasha: 算了你身边是不是没有什么
Tasha: Whatever, don't you have something?
Shure: 下面有请我们的第一位拍品
Shure: Now let's welcome our first auction item
Shure: 不是那个哎呦我他怎么断了呢
Shure: No, wait, why did it break?
Shure: 老板你干什么的老板
Shure: Boss, what are you doing, boss?
Tasha: 智性恋啊
Tasha: Sapiosexual, huh?
Tasha: 这个绝对智性
Tasha: This is absolutely sapiosexual
Lucia: 真的吗是我们先来是吗
Lucia: Really, are we first?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Tasha: 是什么学校的
Tasha: Which school is it from?
Tasha: 什么学历的
Tasha: What's the qualification?
Lucia: 啊我吗
Lucia: Oh, me?
Tasha: 真的很聪明吗
Tasha: Really smart?
其他人：他亲学弟
Others: His junior
Tasha: 你你学弟
Tasha: Your junior?
其他人：嗯就是一个专业的吧
Others: Yeah, in the same major
Lucia: 他没有灯
Lucia: He doesn't have a light
Lucia: 而且我的那个欧根纱
Lucia: And my organza
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Lucia: 我发现贴到墙上之后就不好再剪了
Lucia: I found that after sticking it to the wall, it's hard to cut
Lucia: 所以我就光照大概做了一下
Lucia: So I just did the lighting roughly
其他人：:身体非常好
Tasha: 身体非常好
Tasha: Very healthy
Lucia: 理论上说里面应该有一个灯珠
Lucia: Theoretically, there should be a bulb inside
其他人：非常聪明
Others: Very smart
Tasha: 真的吗真的真的
Tasha: Really, really, really?
Lucia: 但是他没有
Lucia: But it doesn't have one
Shure: 好的好的
Shure: Okay, okay
Lucia: 对而且我没有热胶枪
Lucia: And I don't have a hot glue gun
Tasha: 我靠我能骗你
Tasha: Come on, would I lie to you?
Shure: 来吧第第第一位拍拍卖的同学
Shure: Come on, the first student to be auctioned
Tasha: 性格性格嘞
Tasha: Personality, personality?
Lucia: 所以这个这个角
Lucia: So this corner
其他人：好的一比
Others: Very good
Lucia: 我是粘住的但是这个没粘住
Lucia: I glued it, but this part didn't stick
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 骗你个鬼
Tasha: You're kidding me
Shure: 来介绍一下自己的拍品
Shure: Let's introduce your auction item
Tasha: 我怎么加人家呀
Tasha: How do I add this person?
Shure: 就路亚同学先来吧
Shure: Just let Luya go first.
Tasha: 我不知道长什么样呀
Tasha: I don't know what they look like.
Lucia: 啊我来吗好吧稍等一下
Lucia: Oh, should I do it? Okay, hold on a second.
其他人：就这个样
Others: Like this.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Tasha: 那可以啊
Tasha: That works.
Lucia: 那我就还是用这个小狗吧
Lucia: Then I'll just use this little dog.
其他人：我看这个备选1号 哈哈哈
Others: I'll go with candidate number 1, haha.
Lucia: 如果如果我在接下来的如果
Lucia: If, if in the next...
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我在接下来的5分钟之内
Lucia: In the next 5 minutes...
Lucia: 把那个水母修好了
Lucia: I fix that jellyfish...
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
Lucia: 我就我就再我就再来一轮
Lucia: I'll do another round.
其他人：但他要出国了
Others: But he's going abroad.
其他人：没关系啊
Others: That's okay.
Lucia: 就是现在我就只能用这只小狗了
Lucia: So for now, I can only use this little dog.
Tasha: 那不行啊
Tasha: That's not okay.
其他人：行
Others: It's fine.
Tasha: 哪里行啊
Tasha: How is that fine?
Lucia: 对它是一个纸箱小狗
Lucia: Right, it's a paper box dog.
Tasha: 不行啊你
Tasha: No, you can't.
Tasha: 你找的是不是都大学本科的
Tasha: Are you looking for college graduates?
Lucia: 然后本来是做好
Lucia: It was originally made...
Lucia: 是为了放在我们这个房子的一楼门口
Lucia: To be placed at the entrance of our house.
其他人：本科也不行啊
Others: Even college isn't good enough.
Tasha: 不是那人家比我小我怎么好意思嘛
Tasha: No, they're younger than me, how can I be comfortable?
Lucia: 然后左右各一个就相当于一个石狮子
Lucia: Then there would be one on each side like stone lions.
Lucia: 不过它只是一只纸狗
Lucia: But it's just a paper dog.
Tasha: 比你好对
Tasha: They're better than you, right.
Lucia: 对然后因为因为我的水母灯
Lucia: Right, and because my jellyfish lamp...
Lucia: 它因为一些状况
Lucia: Due to some issues...
Lucia: 它没有灯珠
Lucia: It doesn't have LEDs.
Lucia: 并且就是这个腿没有站稳
Lucia: And its legs aren't stable.
Tasha: 那那弟弟不好
Tasha: Well, the little brother isn't good.
Lucia: 所以我决定
Lucia: So I decided...
Lucia: 先用这个小狗来代替它的位置
Lucia: To use this little dog for now.
Lucia: 然后如果有喜欢它的朋友们
Lucia: And if anyone likes it...
Tasha: 那你不结婚吗
Tasha: Aren't you getting married?
Lucia: 就可以尝试出一下价
Tasha: 人家不着急
Lucia: 好像没有什么其他可介绍的
其他人：你急啊
Lucia: 要不先这样
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: 我我有一点
Shure: 好
Tasha: 我妈让我研究生毕业
Shure: 呃对
Shure: 这个路亚同学的这个拍品
Shure: 就是
Shure: 可能跟我们的这个Eagle life的主题
Tasha: 靠你先你靠个大头鬼
Shure: 比较相关
Shure: 就是它是用我们这两天拆的
Shure: 快递的一些箱子
Shure: 做的一些小的手工品
其他人：这个人真的帅
Tasha: 真的吗
Shure: 还是比较环保比较一口的
Shure: It's still quite eco-friendly and straightforward.
其他人：帅的一比
Others: Super handsome.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 起拍价
Shure: Starting bid.
其他人：找一下
Others: Look it up.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 一一个一个一个
Shure: One, one, one, one.
Shure: beat
Shure: Beat.
Shure: 哪位同学好
Shure: Who's up?
Shure: 我们的小杜出来一个beat
Shure: Let's have our little Du give us a beat.
Jake:小狗
Jake: Puppy.
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 小狗小狗啊啊
Tasha: Puppy, puppy, oh.
Lucia: 现在开始拍卖了
Lucia: Now the auction starts.
Shure: 我们的哎
Shure: Our, hey.
Shure: 刚才他他叫什么来着
Shure: What was his name again?
Jake:黄小是吧小
Jake: Huang Xiao, right?
Shure: 黄导是吗
Shure: Director Huang, is it?
Jake:小也许嗯
Jake: Maybe, hmm.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah!
Shure: 啊黄导出了两个beat
Shure: Ah, Nicous put out two beats.
Shure: 还有更高的吗
Shure: Is there a higher bid?
Shure: 两个币子一次
Shure: Two coins, once.
Shure: 两个币子两次
Shure: Two coins, twice.
Shure: 两臂的三次
Shure: Two coins, three times.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Sold!
Lucia: 哪哪哪位同学来着啊
Lucia: Which student was it again?
Shure: 好现在交还你的两个药剂
Shure: Alright, now return your two potions.
Tasha: 都是被自己的朋友买下来的
Tasha: They were all bought by their own friends.
其他人：这个我要记吗
Others: Should I record this?
Jake:你要记了
Jake: Yes, you should record it.
其他人：捡两币这个币给谁啊
Others: Who gets these two coins?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 小h给了lucyca
Tasha: Nicous gave them to Lucia.
其他人：小H变成9了哈哈哈
Others: Nicous now has 9, haha.
Lucia: 都给我了哈哈哈
Lucia: They all went to me, haha.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Tasha: 好了他的b全部转移了
Tasha: Alright, all his coins are transferred.
其他人：现在两个了
Others: Now there are two.
Jake:2
Jake: Two.
Shure: 路亚现在是两个bees对
Shure: Now Luya has two coins, right?
Tasha: 这不是两个
Tasha: This isn't two.
Tasha: 好像是他身上所有的
Tasha: It seems like it's all he has.
Lucia: 对谢谢
Lucia: Yes, thank you.
其他人：你现在一共多少个
Others: How many do you have in total now?
其他人： 张哥一共多少个
Others: Zhang, how many in total?
Tasha: 两个两个
Tasha: Two, two.
Lucia: 两个这不刚开始吗哈哈
Lucia: Two, it's just the beginning, haha.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
其他人：你卖什么
Others: What are you selling?
Shure: 那我们下面有请第2个拍品
Shure: Now, let's move on to the next auction item.
Tasha: 卖买什么
Tasha: Selling, buying what?
Tasha: 你要买吗
Tasha: Do you want to buy?
其他人：我不买我送你一个
Others: I don't want to buy, I'll give you one.
Tasha: 你送给你女朋友送什么
Tasha: What are you giving your girlfriend?
Tasha: 送你一个
Tasha: I'll give you one.
Tasha: 我拿出来
Tasha: I'll take it out.
Tasha: 接下来拍啥
Tasha: What's the next auction item?
Lucia: 啊这是我们刚开始的时候
Lucia: Ah, this was when we just started.
Lucia: 我给大家每人买一束鲜花
Lucia: I bought a bouquet of flowers for everyone.
Lucia: 然后放花瓶里养
Lucia: Then we put them in vases to take care of.
Lucia: 然后买的是那个呃
Lucia: And I bought, um...
Lucia: 白百合和黄的百合
Lucia: White lilies and yellow lilies.
Lucia: 还有那个康乃馨和芍药
Lucia: Also carnations and peonies.
Lucia: 然后这都是我们自己种的
Lucia: These are all grown by us.
Lucia: 然后就它慢慢开了以后
Lucia: Then, as they slowly bloomed,
Lucia: 我们就把它放在那个压花器里面压
Lucia: We put them in the flower press.
Lucia: 然后压两三天以后
Lucia: After pressing for two or three days,
Lucia: 晒干以后给大家做成这种书签
Lucia: We dried them and made them into bookmarks for everyone.
Lucia: 然后就是
Lucia: And then...
Lucia: 对就可以放书里面
Lucia: Yes, you can put them in books.
Lucia: 然后芍药的话还挺香
Lucia: Peonies are quite fragrant.
Lucia: 然后还有这种明信片
Lucia: We also made postcards.
Lucia: 就是明信片的话就是会少一
Lucia: As for postcards, there are fewer of them.
Lucia: 起拍一下
Lucia: Start bidding.
Lucia: 嗯那就是两
Lucia: Hmm, so that's two.
Lucia: 2个就1EGO币
Lucia: Two for 1 EGO coin.
Lucia: 起拍
Lucia: Starting bid.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 一份明信片加
Shure: One set of postcards plus...
Shure: 一个书签
Shure: One bookmark.
Tasha: 我不吃
Tasha: I'm not eating.
Shure: 你这个量有点多
Shure: The amount you have is a bit much.
Tasha: 之前不是说了吗
Tasha: Didn't I mention before?
Tasha: 那个种子纸你知道吗
Tasha: Do you know about seed paper?
Shure: 要不我们重新定一下价呢
Shure: How about we adjust the price?
Tasha: 嗯每个都
Tasha: Hmm, each one...
Shure: 那我们就是四个
Shure: Then we'll have four.
Tasha: 怎么样是不是挺好看的
Tasha: How does it look? Isn't it pretty?
Shure: 四个来对两
Shure: Four for two.
其他人：我俩合资
Others: We'll pool our money.
Shure: 2+2 好吧
Shure: 2+2, okay?
Tasha: 然后把这个纸你看
Tasha: And then this paper, you see,
Tasha: 撕碎之后送在土壤里面就可以发芽
Tasha: Tear it up and plant it in the soil, and it will sprout.
Shure: 两个书签加两个明信片
Shure: Two bookmarks plus two postcards.
Tasha: 对自己设计的怎么样
Tasha: Yes, how do you like my design?
Shure: 起拍价一个一勾币
Shure: Starting bid, one EGO coin each.
Tasha: 懂了吗懂了懂了
Tasha: Got it? Got it.
其他人：懂了
Others: Got it.
Tasha: 懂了帮我介绍一下行吗
Tasha: Got it, can you introduce him to me?
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two.
其他人：是不是要送我一个
Others: Are you giving me one?
Tasha: 是送你一个
Tasha: Yes, giving you one.
Shure: 这个非常吉利啊
Shure: This is very auspicious.
Tasha: 我直接倒了啊
Tasha: I'll pour it directly.
Shure: 两个一次三个
Shure: Two at a time, three.
Tasha: 我让你送给女朋友
Tasha: I want you to give it to your girlfriend.
Tasha: 我没让你倒卖
Tasha: Not for reselling.
Lucia: 三
Lucia: Three.
Tasha: 你上去等会能介绍一下他吗
Tasha: Can you introduce him when you go up?
其他人：能能能
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
其他人：那没事那没事
Others: No problem, no problem.
Shure: 落子无悔啊
Shure: No regrets.
Tasha: 我的定价是一个EGO币
Tasha: My price is one EGO coin.
Shure: 落子无悔我们
Shure: No regrets for us.
其他人：太贵了啊
Others: Too expensive.
Shure: 三个一次
Shure: Three at a time.
Tasha: 太贵了
Tasha: Too expensive.
Tasha: 那就一个EEG币一个
Tasha: Then one EEG coin each.
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three, twice.
Shure: 三个三次
Shure: Three, three times.
Jake:自自己人后台无价哈哈
Jake: For us, it's priceless at the backstage, haha.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Deal.
Shure: 好的我们第一组书签
Shure: Okay, our first group of bookmarks.
Tasha: 你跟他说一个EGO币起卖
Tasha: Tell him the starting price is one EGO coin.
Shure: 家明信片
Shure: Family postcards.
其他人：先不要着急
Others: Don't rush.
Tasha: 6个打包
Tasha: Six-pack.
Tasha: 5个EGO币 一起卖算了 6个
Tasha: Five EGO coins, let's sell them together, six.
其他人：我先把钱攒够
Others: Let me save up the money first.
Jake:还贷款拍卖
Jake: Auction for repaying loans.
其他人：自己藏的吗
Others: Did you hide it yourself?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：自己藏自己找是吧
Others: You hid it and now you're finding it yourself, right?
Jake:自嘲自讨
Jake: Self-mockery, self-seeking.
其他人：哎我要找他
Others: Hey, I need to find him.
其他人：我已经散尽家财
Others: I've already spent all my fortune.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：我只参与了一次成功的拍卖
Others: I only participated in one successful auction.
其他人：好我已经散尽家财了
Others: Okay, I already spent all my money.
Shure: 好这是第一组
Shure: Alright, this is the first group.
Shure: 第二组起拍
Shure: Starting the second group.
其他人：一共有几组
Others: How many groups are there?
Lucia: 两
Lucia: Two.
Shure: 还有还有两组啊
Shure: There are still two more groups.
Shure: 两个三个
Shure: Two, three...
Shure: 三个一次三个
Shure: Three once, three...
Shure: 两次 3个
Shure: Twice, three...
Shure: 还有没有加价的
Shure: Any more bids?
Shure: 了last time
Shure: Last time...
Shure: so
Shure: So...
Shure: 是这么喊的吧
Shure: Is this how you call it?
Shure: 好还有最后一组
Shure: Alright, we have the final group.
Shure: 起拍价1 一个两个
Shure: Starting bid, one, one, two...
Shure: 两个一次两个两次哦
Shure: Two once, two twice...
Tasha: 你一定要好好介绍
Tasha: You need to properly introduce it.
Tasha: 你要说
Tasha: You should say...
Tasha: 他是种下去可以长出太阳花的
Tasha: It can grow sunflowers when planted.
Shure: 3个一次还有人要加价吗
Shure: Three once, anyone want to bid more?
Tasha: 听到了吗
Tasha: Did you hear that?
其他人：四个
Others: Four!
Alice:个四个啊
Alice: Four, huh?
Shure: 4个哎呦
Shure: Four, wow.
Jake:啊这么有钱啊
Jake: Wow, so rich.
Tasha: 这么有钱啊
Tasha: So rich.
其他人：有钱我有150个
Others: Rich, I have 150.
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈啊账账本不算啊
Shure: Haha, well, that doesn't count.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Tasha: 我有四个啊他
Tasha: I have four, he...
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 啊他他就想想四个来吧
Shure: Ah, he just wants to bid four, come on.
Shure: 那四个一次四个两次
Shure: Four once, four twice...
其他人：我草别人掉了
Others: Damn, someone dropped...
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: soul四个三次
Shure: Soul four times three
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 救死好谢谢老板
Shure: Thanks a lot, boss.
Shure: 记好账啊记好账
Shure: Make sure you keep track of the accounts.
Shure: 那剩下这些就一起出来一次
Shure: Let's finish the rest in one go.
其他人：记了还我吧破产了
Others: Write it down, I'm broke.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 行吧还是你想留留几个
Shure: Okay, or do you want to keep a few?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Tasha: 等我把我的东西卖了我替你还上债爹
Tasha: Let me sell my stuff and I'll pay off your debt.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
其他人：你先你先
Others: You go first, you go first.
Shure: 留着OK好的
Shure: Keep them, okay sure.
其他人：一共有几个啊
Others: How many in total?
其他人：你一共几个
其他人：现在是连4个连10个
Others: Now it's 4 in a row, 10 in a row.
其他人：OK
Others: OK
Tasha: 西比如夫斯
Tasha: Sisyphus
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 你不是150个吗
Lucia: Weren't you supposed to have 150?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Shure: 然后刚刚他们两位的还还是他们两位
Shure: So it was still the two of them just now.
Shure: 他们三位每人是
Shure: The three of them each have...
Shure: 减了3你减了没
Shure: Subtract 3, did you subtract it?
其他人：你现在多少
Others: How many do you have now?
Lucia: 没没没买没没花出去
Lucia: No, no, I didn't buy, didn't spend.
Lucia: 哈哈哈他一共多少了
Lucia: Hahaha, how much does he have in total?
Shure: 还还有谁花了三来着啊他三
Shure: Who else spent three? Ah, he spent three.
其他人：他一共多少了
Others: How much does he have in total?
Lucia: 他我0 我现在就没了
Lucia: He, I have zero. I have nothing now.
其他人：我0 我现在已经没了我已经没了
Others: I'm at zero, I have nothing now, I have nothing left.
Shure: 他那个黄岛黄岛
Shure: That Yellow Island, Yellow Island...
其他人：他你一共多少了
Others: How much do you have in total?
Alice:你一共多少了
Alice: How much do you have in total?
其他人：他刚十一
Others: He just has eleven.
其他人：他跟十一
Others: He's at eleven.
Shure: 他没变他没变还是酒嗯
Shure: He hasn't changed, still nine.
Tasha: 九啊九小这两个也没变
Tasha: Nine, yeah. These two haven't changed either.
Lucia: 我们仨都没发出去
Lucia: None of the three of us sent anything out.
其他人：这不是十一张啊
Others: Isn't that eleven cards?
Lucia: 太可惜了哈哈哈
Lucia: What a pity, hahaha.
Shure: 非常可惜
Shure: Very unfortunate.
其他人：十一那个是9
Others: Eleven, that's nine.
Shure: 那个请那个常务人员不要哄抬物价啊
Shure: Please, staff, don't inflate prices.
Shure: 来吧下一位拍卖者
Shure: Alright, next bidder.
Shure: welcome any host animal
Shure: Welcome any host animal.
Tasha: 你上吧
Tasha: You go ahead.
Tasha: 不是你刷吗
Tasha: Isn't it your turn?
Tasha: 啊刷你先刷
Tasha: Ah, you go first.
Tasha: 红抬一下价格
Tasha: Raise the price a bit.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Lucia: 啊我的我的CP
Lucia: Ah, my CP.
Tasha: 这个头美这个头美这个头美
Tasha: This head is beautiful, this head is beautiful.
Lucia: 我的CP来了
Lucia: My CP is here.
Tasha: 真的吗等会我找找照片
Tasha: Really? Wait, I'll find a picture.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 这是
Shure: This is...
Tasha: 等会抬到两个
Tasha: Wait, raise it to two.
Alice:Lucia的CP狗
Alice: Lucia's CP dog.
Tasha: 哈哈哈抬到最后四分钟分你一个
Tasha: Hahaha, raise it to the last four minutes and I'll give you one.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure: 他叫二狗
Shure: His name is Ergou.
Alice:露西亚狗的CP狗
Alice: Lucia's dog CP.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈突然打人
Lucia: Hahaha, suddenly hits someone.
Tasha: 等他出三个我就分你一个
Tasha: When he gets to three, I'll give you one.
Tasha: 我拿俩好
Tasha: I'll take two, okay?
Alice:大家可以
Alice: Everyone can...
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Tasha: 怎么样
Tasha: How about that?
Alice:大家可以叫它二哈
Alice: You can call it Erha.
Tasha: 咱俩对交叉二哈哈哈
Tasha: We both should bid for the second one, haha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Haha.
Alice:啊其实我本来准备的是水仙种子
Alice: Actually, I originally prepared some daffodil seeds.
Alice:但是我屁都太狠了
Alice: But I was too lazy.
Alice:我忘买了
Alice: I forgot to buy them.
Alice:然后就做了一只纸狗
Alice: So I made a paper dog instead.
Alice:然后这个纸狗的话赠送一个卫生纸
Alice: And this paper dog comes with a piece of toilet paper.
Alice:捏的花已经别到他的耳朵上了
Alice: The flower I made is already pinned to its ear.
Alice:好就这样
Alice: Alright, that's it.
Alice:起拍价一个
Alice: Starting bid is one.
Alice:咱俩不用哄抬
Alice: We don't need to inflate the price.
Alice:因为我还会捏
Alice: Because I can make more.
Alice:哈哈哈好一个起拍
Alice: Haha, okay, starting bid is one.
其他人： 一个
Others: One.
Shure: 一个一个一次
Shure: One, one, going once.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 一个两次这可比露西亚多一朵花呀
Shure: One, going twice, this has more flowers than Lucia's!
Tasha: 哄抬一下
Tasha: Raise the price a bit.
其他人：哄抬哄抬我就负了
Others: Raise it, raise it, I'll go bankrupt.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：我就负资产
Others: I'll be in debt.
Shure: 那我们
Shure: Then we...
Tasha: 我赚到的
Tasha: I made a profit.
Tasha: 我帮你还两个啊
Tasha: I'll help you pay back two.
Shure: 哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh wow.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 啊我说哄抬我的
Tasha: Oh, I meant to raise mine.
Tasha: 我的哈哈
Tasha: Mine, haha.
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two.
Jake:你哪来的钱
Jake: Where did you get the money?
其他人：我我我受
Others: I, I, I got tricked.
其他人：我受到蒙骗
Others: I got tricked.
其他人：我我退出拍卖了
Others: I'm withdrawing from the auction.
其他人：我退出拍卖了
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 那就还是一个
Shure: So, it's still just one.
Shure: SO
Tasha: 上
Tasha: Go
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Shure: 有没有敲得更响一点的东西
Shure: Is there anything that can make a louder sound?
Tasha: 上小弟
Tasha: Go ahead
Tasha: 付4块钱
Tasha: Pay 4 yuan
Tasha: 我帮你还了
Tasha: I covered it for you
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice:给你留着吧哈哈哈你多买点哈
Alice: Keep it, hahaha. Buy more stuff, ha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
其他人：不你得站上面啊
Others: No, you need to stand on it.
Tasha: 你站你去就行
Tasha: Just stand there, you can do it.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
其他人：我我来卖 东西了
Others: I'm here to sell things.
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
其他人：我的我是一个代理人
Others: I'm an agent.
Lucia: 代理代沟代理哈
Lucia: Agent, generation gap agent, ha.
其他人：代理人代理人
Others: Agent, agent.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Tasha: 代购
Tasha: Proxy purchase
其他人：这个是我姐做的
Others: This was made by my sister.
Tasha: 哈哈哈呃
Tasha: Hahaha, uh
Lucia: 哈哈代沟
Lucia: Hahaha, generation gap.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
其他人：想一下怎么拆
Others: Think about how to dismantle it.
Jake:想一下怎么变
Jake: Think about how to change it.
其他人：我就这么说吧
Others: Let me just say it like this.
其他人：这个东西从这个主题上来说
Others: This thing, from this theme,
其他人：它是一个很环保的种子书签
Others: it is a very eco-friendly seed bookmark.
其他人：然后你们把这个东西
Others: And then you guys take this thing...
其他人：倒在倒在那个土壤里浇水
Others: Pour it into the soil and water it.
其他人：它就能生成种子
Others: Then it can produce seeds.
其他人：这是生成太阳花哦
Others: This will grow sunflowers.
其他人：太阳花商品的实际价值
Others: The actual value of the sunflower product.
其他人：但是商品的附加价值就非常屌
Others: But the added value of the product is really amazing.
其他人：你们买了这个就和我姐建立了联系
Others: If you buy this, you'll establish a connection with my sister.
Shure: 你们
Shure: You guys
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
其他人：哈哈哈我姐是个什么人
Others: Hahaha, what kind of person is my sister?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha
其他人：是一个一晚上男人
Others: She's a one-night man.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha
其他人：你们只要认识了他
Others: As long as you know him
其他人：人生就一帆风顺
Others: Your life will be smooth sailing.
Tasha: 这个起拍价直接从一EGO币起拍
Tasha: The starting price is directly from 1 EGO coin.
Tasha: 哈哈哈一把胡子一个
Tasha: Haha, one beard each.
其他人：一个
Others: One
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Shure: 你这不行
Shure: This won't work.
Shure: 市场监督管理局提醒您
Shure: The Market Supervision Administration reminds you.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 你这总共有几个
Shure: How many do you have in total?
Shure: 6个总共6个
Shure: Six, a total of six.
Shure: 两个一个吧
Shure: Two for one, right?
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 我们不希望东西它不是成对出现的
Shure: We don't want things to appear in pairs.
Shure: 对吧多孤独啊
Shure: Right? It's so lonely.
其他人：没问好的
Others: No questions.
Shure: 好的那我们一一勾臂
Shure: Alright, let's link arms.
Shure: 两个种子包
Shure: Two seed packs.
其他人：可以吗
Others: Is that okay?
Shure: 起拍
Shure: Start the bidding.
其他人： 2
Others: 2.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:走一下流程了都
Jake: Let's go through the process.
Shure: 两个还有更高的吗
Shure: Two, anyone higher?
Shure: 两个一次
Shure: Two once.
Shure: 哎呦黄岛还是大气
Shure: Wow, Nicous is generous.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 3个3个一次还有人要加价吗
Shure: Three, three once, anyone want to raise?
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three twice.
Shure: 三个三次成交
Shure: Three times, sold.
Shure: 好的第二轮拍卖
Shure: Okay, second round of auction.
Shure: 一一个起拍一两个2两个一次
Shure: Starting with one, one, two, two once.
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two twice.
Shure: 两个3次
Shure: Two three times.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Sold.
Tasha: 好等会再轰抬一次二
Tasha: Alright, let's raise the bid next.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Shure: 最后一份
Shure: Last one.
Shure: 啊还有最后一份
Shure: Ah, there's still one more.
Shure: 两个一次
Shure: Two once.
Shure: 还有出更高的吗
Shure: Anyone higher?
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two twice.
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 大声快点
Tasha: Louder, hurry up.
Shure: 还有还有
Shure: More, more.
Shure: 出嫁了吗
Shure: Sold?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：三三三
Others: Three, three, three.
Lucia: 好好好哈哈哈
Lucia: Alright, alright, hahaha.
Alice:好好好哈哈哈
Alice: Alright, alright, hahaha.
其他人：好好
Others: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 好好哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Okay, okay, hahaha.
Shure: 四个一次
Shure: Four at once.
Shure: 四个两次
Shure: Four twice.
Tasha: 记着
Tasha: Remember.
Shure: 四个三次成交
Shure: Four three times, sold.
其他人：啊好
Others: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 怎么样好
Tasha: How about it, okay?
Tasha: 回回你俩好
Tasha: You two are good.
其他人：爽了姐哈哈哈
Others: Feeling good, sis, hahaha.
Shure: OK我们host auction部分还有
Shure: Okay, our host auction part still has...
Tasha: 给你这是黄牛价
Tasha: Here, this is the scalper price.
Shure: 大家要拍卖物品吗
Shure: Does anyone want to auction items?
Tasha: 来
Tasha: Come on.
Lucia: 我现在下去做去哈哈
Lucia: I'm going down to do it now, haha.
其他人：给我这么多
Others: Give me so much.
其他人：卧槽我回本了
Others: Whoa, I'm even now.
Shure: okay好的
Shure: Okay, alright.
Lucia: 真的我想起来我那没拆
Lucia: Really, I just remembered I haven't unpacked that.
Shure: 那
Shure: Then...
Lucia: 大家先玩着
Lucia: You guys play first.
Shure: 那现在没有了这个host auction的部分
Shure: Now there's no more of this host auction part.
Tasha: 把你的负债还了
Tasha: Pay off your debt.
Shure: 然后我们现在进入到下一part
Shure: Now we're moving on to the next part.
Tasha: 怎么样帮我上去一趟
Tasha: How about helping me go up there?
Shure: 刚刚大家已经花了很多钱
Shure: Everyone has already spent a lot of money.
Tasha: 场上有人
Tasha: There are people on stage.
Tasha: 场下有人
Tasha: There are people off stage.
Shure: 来购入这些host的拍卖品
Shure: Come on, buy these host auction items.
Tasha: 四个
Tasha: Four.
Shure: 对吧然后所以下一个环节
Shure: Right, so the next segment...
Shure: 大家可以来上台
Shure: Everyone can come on stage.
Shure: 简单的进行一个自我介绍
Shure: And give a simple self-introduction.
Shure: 然后根据你自我介绍的
Shure: Then based on your self-introduction...
Shure: 我们再发放一波一钩币
Shure: We'll distribute another round of Hook Coins.
Shure: 有哪位自告奋勇的
Shure: Who wants to volunteer...
Shure: 先上来自我介绍一下
Shure: To come up and introduce themselves?
Shure: 那肯定有跟你没有关系gas的环节
Shure: There must be a segment that has nothing to do with you, gas.
Shure: 嗯有哪位想introduction
Shure: Hmm, anyone wants to do an introduction?
Alice:新课满3减2
Alice: New course, buy 3 get 2 off.
Alice:什么发一期课
Alice: What, release a course?
Shure: 没有没有也
Shure: No, no, not that.
Shure: 那个可以不介绍
Shure: You don't need to introduce that.
Shure: 可以给大家讲个笑话讲个故事
Shure: You can tell a joke or a story.
Shure: 都可以就是只要你上台来我就会
Shure: Anything is fine, as long as you come on stage, I will...
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone...
Shure: 评委席就会根据表现来给各位打分
Shure: The judges will score you based on your performance.
Shure: 并且发放一个币
Shure: And you'll receive a token.
Shure: 有自告奋勇的吗
Shure: Any volunteers?
Shure: 展示才艺也可以
Shure: You can also show off a talent.
Alice:刘婷会唱歌
Alice: Liu Ting can sing.
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Anyone else?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：在这哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
其他人：你怎么不杀了我呢
Others: Why don't you kill me then?
其他人：你先打个样
Others: You go first.
其他人：你先扣自己的币
Others: You deduct your own token first.
其他人：打个样我扣上就是第一个上来夹的
Others: You go first, I'll follow as the first one to join.
其他人：抠自己了
Others: Deduct your own token.
Shure: 我给大家自我介绍一下
Shure: Let me introduce myself.
Shure: 大家好
Shure: Hello, everyone.
Shure: 低调低调低调
Shure: Humble, humble, humble.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 大家好对
Shure: Hello everyone, yeah.
Shure: 我叫秀硕
Shure: My name is Shure.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Shure: 对我来自    大学
Shure: Yes, I'm from Beijing University of Posts and Telecommunications.
Shure: 然后是一位大四的文科生
Shure: And I'm a senior in liberal arts.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哦你刚刚说的JK金康是金康啊
Tasha: Oh, you just said JK Jin Kang, is it Jin Kang?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
其他人： 上一个也是吗
Others: Was the last one too?
Shure: 怎么样怎么样
Shure: How is it, how is it?
Shure: How is it? How is it?
Shure: 这个这个介绍还是不错的吧
Shure: This introduction is pretty good, right?
Tasha: 哦他是单身啊
Tasha: Oh, he's single?
Shure: 你说好了
Shure: You agreed.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Shure: 那你要上来introduction一下嘛
Shure: So, do you want to come up and give an introduction?
Tasha: 卑鄙卑鄙啊
Tasha: Despicable, despicable!
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha
Tasha: 哦没事
Tasha: Oh, it's fine.
Shure: 没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 哎呦大家活跃一点嘛
Shure: Come on, everyone, be more lively!
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 活跃一点对
Shure: Be more lively, yeah.
其他人：你是人吗
Others: Are you human?
Shure: 跟大家
Shure: With everyone...
Tasha: 哈哈怎么了
Tasha: Haha, what's wrong?
Alice:大家哈
Alice: Everyone, ha.
其他人：我又怎么了
Others: What did I do again?
Shure: 大家都是各位的亲朋好友
Shure: Everyone here is friends and family.
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Shure: 其实也没有没有什么害羞的
Shure: There's really nothing to be shy about.
Tasha: 不知道我就突然间反应过来
Tasha: I don't know, I just suddenly reacted.
Shure: 主要就是想让其他的同学
Shure: Mainly, I just want other classmates...
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Shure: 就是来也互相认识一下
Shure: To come and get to know each other.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Shure: 毕竟一会还有顿晚餐呢
Shure: After all, there's dinner later.
Shure: 大家就是尬在那里也不好是吧
Shure: It wouldn't be good if everyone just sat there awkwardly, right?
Tasha: 那你是人吗
Tasha: Are you human?
Shure: 没有的话我可点名了啊
Shure: If no one comes up, I'll start calling names.
Tasha: 我靠像老师一样哈哈
Tasha: Damn, like a teacher, haha.
Tasha: 干嘛呀这还有好多呢
Tasha: Why? There's still a lot left.
Shure: 对我现在啊
Shure: Yeah, right now...
Tasha: 你要吗你揪他耳朵上的哇磕到了
Tasha: Do you want it? You pull his ear... oh, he got hurt.
Shure: 开始往上加
Shure: I'll start adding now.
Shure: 加爆
Shure: Add a lot.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure: 后面的拍品会还有更好的啊
Shure: The items later will be even better.
Shure: 一个有没有人上来讲
Shure: So, does anyone want to come up and speak?
Shure: 两个了啊
Shure: That's two now.
其他人：完了你这个你这个家长
Others: Oh no, you're such a parent.
其他人：我怕是不会有人上去的
Others: I doubt anyone would go up there.
其他人：因为你把那段全拍完
Others: Because you filmed that whole section.
Alice:你应该是从高往低拍
Alice: You should film from high to low.
Alice:你说现实
Alice: You mean realistically?
Alice:你怎么一个一往上
Alice: Why are you filming upwards?
Alice:大家肯定都不上心哈哈哈
Alice: No one will take it seriously, haha.
其他人：放心吧现实也会有人上去
Others: Don't worry, in real life, someone will go up.
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What's up?
其他人：没事
Others: Nothing.
其他人：看看你眼睛里有
Others: Let's see what's in your eye.
Shure: 一答10个
Shure: Answer 10 questions.
Tasha: 十个十个
Tasha: Ten, ten.
Shure: 10个开始往下捡
Shure: Start picking up from 10.
Tasha: 还有
Tasha: There's more.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：人家在引诱你呢
Others: They're tempting you.
Tasha: 多少个
Tasha: How many?
其他人：一夜暴富
Others: Get rich overnight.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Tasha: 40 块钱
Tasha: 40 bucks.
其他人：你在等什么
Others: What are you waiting for?
Tasha: 谁在等什么
Tasha: Who's waiting?
其他人：杜卓宇大家可以叫我小杜
Others: Du Zhuoyu, you can call me Xiao Du.
Tasha: 然后我就是AK刘宇权的小弟
Tasha: And I'm AK Liu Yuquan's follower.
其他人：刘宇轩小弟啊
Others: Liu Yuxuan's follower, huh?
其他人：我们就去年去年认识的
Others: We met last year.
其他人：AK是什么
Others: What's AK?
其他人：然后我今年是在北京实习
Others: I'm interning in Beijing this year.
其他人：然后过两天我就走了
Others: And in a few days, I'll be leaving.
Tasha: 又称我的别名是什么
Tasha: What's my other nickname?
其他人：然后很高就会跟你主演
Others: And you'll be acting as the lead.
其他人：我操磕到了
Others: Ouch, I bumped into something.
其他人：然后我也是做
Others: And I also do...
Tasha: 我是AK刘宇轩的小弟
Tasha: I'm AK Liu Yuxuan's follower.